monseigneur gollnisch bonjour merci
d'être en direct avec nous sur rt france
alors tout d'abord votre organisme
intervient auprès des écoles et des
hôpitaux de la communauté chrétienne qui
ont été détruits et dans la double
explosion ainsi que des quartiers
historiques on le rappelle un ce drame a
particulièrement touché le quartier
dense schafier écart tient quartier à
majorité chrétienne
est-ce que vous avez une idée de
l'ampleur des dégâts constatés sur place
oui bonjour les dégâts sont
considérables bien sûr comme vous le dit
fort bien les cartilages marché a été
extrêmement touché la cathédrale
orthodoxe saint georges et la cathédrale
maronite qui s'appelle également saint
georges ont été durement abîmé la pital
orthodoxe saint georges aussi
l'archevêché maronite de beyrouth a été
très abîmée ainsi que d'autres églises
ceci au milieu des destructions
évidemment de logements de maison et
donc les dégâts sont en effet
considérables les blessés l'arrêt de la
v2 de l'économie tout cela est
évidemment épouvantables dans un pays
qui est déjà en crise comme vous savez
soit impliqué sur le plan politique et
sur le plan sanitaire évidemment avec la
cueillette 19 alors le coût des dommages
a été chiffré à plus de 3 milliards de
dollars vous avez lancé un appel aux
dons pour aider à la reconstruction des
hôpitaux mais aussi des écoles
appartenant aux églises et aux
congrégations locale khaled
préconisez-vous pour accompagner les
libanais justement alors je crois qu'il
faut maintenir cet appel pour les écoles
car
ma rentrée même avoir lieu dans des
écoles qui n'auront pas été détruite en
dehors de en dehors de beyrouth et par
conséquent il nous faut préparer sa
rentrée le risque qu'il y avait qu il ya
encore sexy écoles ferment du liban par
conséquent ce serait très grave car ces
écoles tenu par les chrétiens sont des
lieux de sociabilité
il ya des élèves chrétiens et des élèves
musulmans il y à une éducation au
respect mutuel dans ces écoles de
chrétiennes c'est donc très important
que ces écoles ou en septembre donc
l'effort doit être maintenu maintenant
évidemment pour beyrouth il ya un effort
supplémentaire qui va d'abord dépend de
la communauté internationale nous mêmes
sommes une association nous n'avons pas
les moyens des trois cent mille
personnes qui tombent en plus de
logement mais comme ça montre un bon
réseau d'amis sur le terrain nous
pouvons aider les organisations
internationales les puissances
nationales ou 6 à agir là où il faut
vraiment agir c'est à dire pour l'aide
de la population
je voudrais relever si vous me le
permettez juste en deux phrases
nous devons être conscients que le liban
est un élément clé dans le moyen-orient
parce que c'est le pays où vraiment il
ya une liberté c'est le seul pays de la
région dans lequel il a une vraie dette
et religieuse la liberté de culte existe
partout sauf en arabie saoudite où
pourtant il y a deux millions de
chrétiens vivent les travailleurs mais
il n'y a pas de pub sans ça la liberté
de culte existe n'est pas la liberté
religieuse
autrement dit il n'ya qu'au liban il ya
une vraie liberté religieuse alors je
sais que certains va le remettre en
cause le système confessionnel
il faut sans doute l'améliorer pour
éviter
la corruption c'est certain mais faisons
très attention ne notons pas en cause un
système qui a donné la liberté au lieu à
un pays du moyen orient
liberty religieux ça veut dire notamment
des fêtes de quoi changer de religion
le fait pour un chrétien d'épouser une
musulmane
ce qui est impossible dans les autres
pays acadien qui veut épouser une
musulmane doit devenir musulman alors je
suis un peu étonné de voir certains qui
elles sont treize en charge contre le
système professionnel du liban
et encore une fois le il doit être
amélioré mais qui n'ont jamais un mot
pour critiquer l'absence de liberté
religieuse dans les autres pays alors
emmanuel macron était hier en visite à
beyrouth
il a dit comprendre la colère de la
population on sait que la population est
très remonté contre le gouvernement et
sa gestion justement de la situation sur
place
un pays qui est frappé comme vous l'avez
dit par une crise économique majeure une
crise politique est également la crise
du coc vidé ce que vous partagez cette
cette colère est ce que c'est un
sentiment que voilà que vous ressentez
vous aussi alors moi je crois que cette
colère elle appartient elle appartient
aux libanais et moi je suis un citoyen
français je comprends la colère de nos
amis de mes amis mais moi je n'ai pas à
m'immiscer il demande de la situation
politique du liban
je crois que les propos du président
macron rejoignez en effet l agacement de
la colère de la population me permets
d'insister sur le fait que les autorités
françaises n'ont pas simplement
deux bandes et des réformes aux
responsables politiques
ils ont également annoncé qu'il y avait
11 milliards sur la table qu'ils étaient
prêts à venir aider les libanais c'est
d'abord cela nous sommes prêts à vous
aider
il y à 11 milliards ce qui n'est pas une
petite somme il y à un milliard de la
communauté internationale pour aider les
libanais c'est d'abord cela il ya 11
milliards simplement les 11 millions ne
peuvent pas être donné et si la classe
politique est corrompue si nous ne
sommes pas certains messieurs 11
milliards vont effectivement aller et
délais l'année s'est passé les simples
en fait comme comme eux comme attitude
mais j'insiste sur quel est le premier
message c'est l'aide à des prêts là dès
la dernière question c'est que l'aide
française doit permettre justement
peuple libanais d'agir en liberté
certaines autres êtes peuvent cacher
certaine volonté de prendre justement le
contrôle du liban est ce qu'on peut
craindre
voilà de nouvelles tensions à cause de
ces de ces aides internationales
oui bien sûr tout le monde sait qu'il ya
quatre groupes religieux qui structure
la société au liban les chrétiens
catholiques orthodoxes protestants les
sunnites les chiites et les druzes et
d'une certaine manière dans l'histoire
du liban
les groupes pour en crue à prendre le
pouvoir tout seul ou liban et chacun de
ces gouttes essayé dans l'histoire du
liban de de prendre le leadership a fait
l'expérience douloureuse que le liban ne
peut exister que dans une collaboration
de ces quatre groupes religieux et c'est
cette collaboration qui fait
l'originalité du libor et par conséquent
effectivement il faut aider le liban
comme l'a demandé le patriarche maronite
être dans une neutralité c'est à dire
qu' aucune de ces et composantes ne soit
dans la dépendance d'un groupe étranger
d'un groupe extérieur
il ya donc un combat contre la
corruption
il ya un combat pour le renouvellement
de la classe politique
il ya un combat pour la neutralité du
liban où la distanciation vis-à-vis et
des pouvoirs extérieurs qui veulent
manipuler lui
merci beaucoup monseigneur gollnisch
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes directeur de
l'oeuvre d'orient merci à vous